The probability of winning
the Powerball lottery
is 1 in 175,223,511.
I'm assuming this is when you
buy a Powerball lottery ticket.
This is a probability.
Then they tell us the
probability of becoming
a billionaire in the
United States is 0.000001.
Which is more likely?
And I assume this
is like saying,
if you were to randomly
select a person at birth, what
is the probability
that that person is
going to become a billionaire?
And that's this number
right over here.
And just looking at this,
it's kind of hard to compare.
So let me try to write the
second number, this decimal,
as a fraction.
And then we might
be able to make
more of a direct comparison.
So 0 point-- and let's
see, we have five 0's.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
And then we have a 1.
And so let's just think about
what place that 1 is in.
This is in the tenths place.
That's the tenths place, that's
the hundredths place, that's
the thousandths place, that's
the ten thousandths place,
and that's the hundred
thousandths place.
And this right over here
is the millionths place.
So this 1 literally
represents 1/1,000,000.
So this is the exact same thing.
This is equivalent
to 1 over 1 million.
This is 1/1,000,000.
This is 1/775,223,511.
So this whole thing,
this whole expression
here is a much smaller value.
We had the same numerator.
We have a 1 in both cases.
This denominator is much larger.
So this entire fraction
is much, much smaller,
actually, by roughly a
factor of 175-- much smaller.
This is roughly 1
over 175 million.
This is 1 over 1 million.
So which is more likely?
Which is more likely if you
were to pick a random person who
bought a lottery ticket, and
the probability of them winning
the Powerball lottery, or if
you were to pick a random person
and you'd say the probability
of them becoming a billionaire?
It's actually far more likely--
roughly 175 times more likely--
that that person could
become a billionaire.
So much more likely
becoming a billionaire.